or Russia's invasion of Ukraine
triggered a certain and massive
humanitarian Exodus since February more
than a million Ukrainian men women and
children have registered with
authorities here in Germany now a new
multi-year study is trying to document
what they've been through researchers
have interviewed thousands of Ukrainian
refugees who are now in Germany trying
to gain insights into the challenges of
integration things like accessing
services and finding School places and
they're documenting the psychological
impact of these experiences
well let's hear directly from someone
who's been through that process Elena
rehovah fled the war in Ukraine and now
lives at here in Berlin welcome to the
studio thank you so much for joining us
now I understand you've been here since
May three or four months uh enter the
war what prompted your decision to seek
Asylum here
um actually When The War Began me and my
friends decided to
leave to the Village nearby the cave
because we thought it would be more safe
and safer but it was a bad decision
because that Village was occupied by
Russian soldiers and who have been
caught of electricity
Heating and etc for weeks and we
couldn't escape because uh every car
which tried to Fleet it
Village was shot by Russian soldiers but
one day it was succeed to escape and we
decided that we need to
goes down go somewhere from from Ukraine
to stay safe so my friends so I decided
to
come to Germany because they were
looking for any country any family that
can accept them and they reached Julia
on one of the websites
she offered for the whole family to come
here in Berlin and basically
there are three families they live in
one house but in separate Flats they
accepted us as a real family they helped
us a lot with our papers financial help
they treat us like a family and I'm not
gonna lie that um
I will be grateful to those people to
the end of my days so they and so how
how many of you uh made it out together
oh
seven people mean seven people and so
you were in this this Village so how did
you how did you escape how did you get
past the Russians
um there was a
Green Way or how should I call it uh
when Ukrainian military forces uh
provides that oh like a corridor yes
succeeded to to escape that day right
and so you arrived in in Germany how
have you you found the process of
navigating a German bureaucracy it
sounds like you you had help yeah we had
a really great help because
um
it's really complicated to get into
papers documents and Etc once you you're
in a foreign country so our German
family I call them German family uh
helped us a lot to go through tour
grounds and Etc to get residence permits
registrations and Etc
how how difficult would that have been
if you if you hadn't had your German
family here
um
I believe more complicated because
you're doing strange forms in a
different language yeah yeah so the
first point and the second Point once
you you're fleeing your country to
escape the war you're a bit lost you
just cannot keep your brain and okay now
I should
make the first step the second step and
Etc
upside down yeah so you need somebody to
be with you and guide you navigate you
and what is that like I understand you
you worked in PR in Ukraine so one day
you're a successful businesswoman then
the next you're asking strangers in a
foreign country and a foreign language
for somewhere to live and something to
eat what is that change like
[Music]
um
actually I think a lot of ukrainians
feels this way
um
you're like creating
um
a temporary life you know you're like
okay the world is crumbling but you know
one day I will be back to Ukraine we
will build the new life better future
and Etc but now I need to think of
creating my temporary life
you know you're treated as a temporary
that's it so one day you will return
oh yeah
but
um
they cannot answer this question like
like 400 because
um
you're building your temporary life
uh in a different country and then once
the war will be finished
uh of course you want to go back to your
Homeland but
still you have your life here as well so
I think a lot of ukrainians will be
considering the way how you can live for
both countries and in your Homeland
and your second country and have you
left anyone back home in Ukraine uh yes
my parents because basically we are from
the netsk so it's the second time we're
experiencing the war and my parents they
don't want to leave Ukraine there like
if it's too much for us right to live
our but you're still in contact with
them and yes they're safe of course well
we thank you for for joining us and and
outlining so clearly what that terrible
decision is like I wish you well thank
you Elena rehover thank you thank you
for telling me
now as we mentioned a little earlier
Russia's invasion of Ukraine has
triggered a sudden and massive
humanitarian Exodus since February more
than one million Ukrainian men women and
children have registered with our
authorities here in Germany and I'm very
pleased to welcome one of the project
leaders working on a survey of the
refugees who have come over here to
Germany doctor
um Professor Dr Katarina who's director
of the federal Institute for population
research in Germany thanks so much for
joining us today here on DW now I
believe the first phase of your study is
now complete can you please tell us more
about the people coming here from
Ukraine and the specific challenges that
they are facing
Yes actually the first phase of our
study is now done and we interviewed
over 11
000 refugees coming to Germany from the
Ukraine these are mostly actually women
80 percent of all the adults are female
we have a relatively young population
the average age is 28 years of age we
have a lot of children
almost half of the women actually
traveled with their children to Germany
and another very important thing is that
the education of these people is
relatively High compared to the Ukraine
population
and moreover we also looked if the
children are in daycare if they are in
school and actually they have started
being in daycare many many me almost
everybody is in school only three
percent have uh just online
schooling with schools in the Ukraine
what about housing because I mean I know
certainly in Berlin it's very
challenging for anyone to find
accommodation here let alone if you're
coming here as a refugee so how much of
a challenge is it for refugees to find
decent accommodation here in Germany
this yes this is of course a real
challenge but we were very surprised
from our results what we actually found
is only nine percent of the refugees are
in so-called group housing and all the
others are in some kind of private
housing Arrangements either with people
and relatives or friends they knew but
the vast majority among those in private
housing really have their own apartment
so they were able to find apartments
where they could move in which is really
very very helpful also for the
integration of these families into
Germany because as I said only a really
small minorities living in these group
housings a very high number of Ukrainian
refugees has come to Germany the only
country to take in more refugees than
Germany is Poland which of course shares
a border with Ukraine can you tell us
what is it that attracts people who are
sick taking shelter to come to Germany
this is a very important question what
we found out is that most of them came
because they knew somebody already
living in Germany and moreover also the
human rights which are which we have in
Germany are another very important
explanation what the refugees told us
why they come to Germany all right
Professor Dr Katarina director of the
federal Institute for population
research in Germany thank you so much
for your time today